park this year would be the cubs
very much embattled not only for a
playoff spot but for the division they
have not yet clinched
a playoff spot and the tight central and
j.t brubaker
continuing his rookie season wilson
contreras
reigning two-time all-star starting
catcher in the national league
that has gone down strikeout for
brubacher
in a scoreless first and now the pirates
coming bath
john lester ready to work seven innings
shy of reaching 1 000.
gonzalez checks in at 325 versus lefties
[Music]
it's a nice clean one two three first
inning for john lester
we go to the second inning kyle
schwarber leads it off and takes a
strike
here's a swing and a line drive right
center field base it toward the alley
over to pick it up is reynolds and
schwarber going for two the throw to
second base
he slides in with a double kyle
schwarber leads off the cubs second
inning with a two base hit to right
center
kyle goes out and gets this fastball
away and hooks it into the
right center gap now they're playing
kyle way around towards left center
in the middle of the diamond so kyle
he's flying around first he goes in
slides into second no real play at
second base and
kyle would lead off double here in the
second inning
and a swing and a miss by bryant who
reacted
like he tweaked something nick frangela
coming out with david ross
and you know kb's trying to talk his way
in maybe
might not be his hand the way he's
shaking his arm it could be his elbow or
shoulder
his right shoulder you could see where
he just kind of
winced when he swung through the pitch
and sometimes if the guy has
the shoulders barking a little bit it's
the swing and miss that affects it more
than anything
schwarber is going to have to hold it
second and bryant is
out chris bryant is out of this game
david bode comes in
clearly tweaked something on this swing
in his first and only at bat tonight and
later was
shaking out his as arm
advances to third with two down
comes hobby hitting seventh
lead off doubles you gotta cash those in
he bunts
and he's gonna make it how about that
one nothing on a javier bias
all right kipnis
now this frank out makes a move hey yeah
you don't have to worry about steals and
strike
down cubs get a run on a two-out bunt
head by baez
gregory polanco and lefty the lefty the
pitch to polanco
the swing and a miss strike three that's
number one for john
the pitch to carratini swinging a miss
carratini
down on strike sets the third k for
brubaker
and top of the order ian happ
got him on strikes man holberg says
three straight strikeouts now for
brubacher
that was right there it's perfect pitch
a strikeout victim his first time around
brubacher with a second strikeout of
contreras he is
fan five cubs kyle schwarber doubled and
scored the game's only run in the second
inning
and a swing and a miss and jt brubacher
the right-hander has struck out
six batters bring up jason kipnis who
struck out swinging jason hitting from
the left side against the righty
brubacher that pitch oh it hit him
up high he was able to turn and got hit
on the back shoulder area kipnis is okay
jogs to first that'll bring up victor
caratiti with two outs a man on first
base
and delivers the pitch is lined in a
right center field
for a base hit this one will roll all
the way to the track
racing around third and coming home is
kipnis the throw
not in time kipnis scores an
rbi double by victor caratini makes it
two to nothing cubs
here in the fifth and half coming to the
plate
a run in for chicago and brubacher
with the fastball his eighth strikeout
but the cubs have a two nothing lead
one down cubs latest two
and the pitch to gonzales bounced slowly
towards short bias to second one
over to first double play a double play
ends the inning the
pirates have challenged that six four
three double play ball we believe
they're challenging
to play at second base is kipnis
foot on the base i think it is
barely maybe a spike touching it out
out bottom of the seventh inning kyle
ryan the new cubs pitcher john lester
with six shutout innings another strong
outing for john it's his game to win the
bullpen will try to do the final
three innings of work to uh
make that win possible for leicester
schwarber got the go ahead rally started
with a lead-off double
in the second and later scored on javi
baez's two out
rbi bunt single
and this one will find the alleyway
two runs are gonna score it's
four nothing
rbi's numbers 22 and 23
for schwarber the 3-2 pitch for bodhi
a broken bat looper left field base hit
hamilton's going to score
easily cubs lead five-nothing broken bat
but what do they say that bat died as a
hero
a run-scoring single into left for david
bodie
and the cubs lead by a high five
got a major league debut coming up jared
oliva
who didn't start in high school
and then walked on at the university of
arizona he has made the big leagues
right down the middle called strike
three cubs win
winkler strikes out the side john lester
gets career win 193
first win since mid-august
they take another step toward a division
championship